in fact i'm going to start
today with our guest steve steve is the
global head
of innovation for both finance and risk
at hsbc
where he leads an innovation ecosystem
that shapes structure
and delivers better ways of serving
their customers through innovative
solutions
he is an accomplished transformation
expert with 28 years of experience in
consulting
telecommunications and financial
services and he guides geographically
diverse teams and drives large-scale
complex strategic
initiatives across multiple
organizations that was a mouthful i hope
you can appreciate that
it's his passion for innovation along
with his growth mindset that drives his
continuous learning and
really is the impetus and the very
reason we are about to have this
conversation today
with himself and jeremy and justin ads
for our two stanford hosts first we have
jeremy utley jeremy is the director of
executive education at the d school
there he is
and an adjunct professor at stanford
school of engineering he's
also and i can personally attest to this
an outstanding collaborator and teaches
many celebrated courses
at stanford we also have it with us
today
justin justin is the founder of the
professional fellowship program at the d
school where he also heeds a
heads up strategic partnerships as an
adjunct professor he's also taught
several popular graduate courses in
design
thinking and organization design
gentlemen it is a pleasure being here
with you today
and please take it away
thank you robin wanted to say hi to
everybody i'm
i'm here in london so good evening to
the people who've joined in london
and uh funny enough i got a ping from
somebody that they're joining from hong
kong
and it's i think one in the morning out
there in hong kong
and somebody else from japan as well so
it's early days
um looking forward to speaking to to
been looking forward to speaking to
justin and jeremy for a while we've got
the uh we've got the earth just about
covered right because justin you're in
hawaii aren't you
yes yes from hawaii to california to
london
all the way to hong kong i mean that's
incredible we've got we've got the globe
covered well it's a
it's a pleasure to get to be with you
steve and justin as always
and today i'm really excited to dig into
a topic that i think is near and dear to
all of our hearts which is
bringing the tools of innovation and
democratizing them
to make them available to folks who
perhaps
prior to encountering them wouldn't have
thought of themselves as creative
i think we are all in the business of um
sparking a sense of creative passion and
possibility
and confidence among folks not just who
are artists
but also who are analysts and so
it's really exciting to get to talk
about how you've been doing that in your
organization
and i guess steve maybe perhaps where we
could start if we just roll back the
clock so to speak
when you set out on this journey what
was the impact you're
hoping for or looking for in the
beginning and maybe how is your vision
of impact
evolved as you have been on the journey
with us
yeah yeah thanks for the question jeremy
and funny enough
the impact has been incredible and i'm
really happy
about that but i started off selfishly
so it was more about myself and how i
wanted to develop myself i knew
i needed to do something different i
wanted to learn about innovation
but i didn't feel like i knew enough to
be able to lead innovation and drive
innovation
so i decided to say all right let me let
me do a google search and find out
where is the best innovation program i
could find
and sure enough i saw the innovation and
entrepreneurship program at stanford
i read through it i read through a lot
of it and i decided to join it
and and i'm glad i did because the first
course i took was actually your course
and it was an online course exactly and
it was around empathize
and as i was going through that i was
like really eating up the information i
was really liking it
and i thought you know imagine if i
could bring this back
and and take my learnings i had a lot of
aha moments
bring it back and how i could have a
wider impact and that was kind of the
genesis
of kind of the creation of this course
and making it available to everybody
maybe maybe we can start there because
there's one thing you said you know we
we invited you to uh to write a series
of blog posts that we've been jointly
publishing
and i was struck by a comment you made i
know the class intimately we filmed it a
few years ago
i remember being in the hyatt in santa
clara back when you know pre-covered
when we were allowed to be in hotels
interviewing people and putting this
footage online and the whole team at the
stanford center for professional
development was saying are you seriously
going to have people go to hotels
and in the early days students would
enroll in the course and they'd send
notes going
wait seriously do i have i thought this
was an online class but
when we say online it's it's a misnomer
of sorts because it still demands that
you engage with the world and
interact with human beings beyond the
screen but
there there's something that you call
that in your blog post which i thought
was great you said at one point in that
course we asked a simple
question when was the last time you
spoke to a customer
and you made a comment there in that
blog post you said that was a penny drop
moment for me and i wonder if you
wouldn't mind
just for yourself because because you
said your journey started primarily with
a learning agenda for yourself and a
growth agenda for yourself
what do you mean that was a penny drop
moment why was it a penny drop moment
and
what kind of change did that spark for
you
um you know it's funny oftentimes people
will think that they know what the
problem is and they'll already sit there
and work what the solution is
and you know i and i see it and and i'm
guilty of it myself i'll go out there
and say oh i know what the problem is
i'm gonna go build the database and then
before i really understand what the
the problem is you know really
understanding what the customer wants
and i you guys have put out some uh
stories about things that got built that
they never talked to customers and how
it
miserably failed and so i thought you
know what
when is the last time i spoke to a
customer right and and doing some of
that exercise
and i really like the hotel example
because
that's what really made it live for me
is you guys forced us to go out to
hotels so i went to london
and i went to interview people in some
london hotels
and i can tell you it becomes
uncomfortable
when you go up to people and say hey can
i interview because they're already
looking at you kind of weird
and like who are you why should i be
talking to you um
and really asking them the the open
ending questions
and stop to listen and use all the tools
that you guys mentioned so while it all
sounds like common sense
uh the reality is when you're in that
position and you have to sit there
and capture insights from people the
structure and the approach that you guys
provide
uh it is incredibly useful to me and
before i thought it was kind of uh very
soft skills but
you guys have a really good structure
and i see how you go from step to step
to step to build on and i really enjoy
that
you know i don't know if it's a finance
thing or what but i'm i'm a finance guy
by training and i always thought of
creativity as kind of
soft skills and what i would say is what
that meant to me was it was frivolous
it was trivial right and so it was
really i remember when i encountered the
the d school you know 15 years ago
myself when i was in business school
i was blown away by how rigorous
creative practice is and how hard it was
i thought you know it's like a clown
training program you know but it's far
from it you mentioned
you mentioned taking risks and the
importance of taking risks
and one thing i would say just and i i
commend you for this
is it's my observation is it's really
easy
inside of many organizations for leaders
to tell others to take risks
but not take a risk themselves i mean i
remember not with your organization but
with another organization
in the united states large financial
services organization we were
working with them to build a capability
around innovation as well we had
very senior leaders involved in the
program we're organizing this massive
immersion in the field where we're going
to go talk to customers and
we've got you know charter buses and the
whole nine yards
and one of the junior team members kind
of came to me and said hey i'm having
trouble
blocking people's calendars can you walk
me through what exactly are we doing
because i need to provide justification
because these are senior people who you
know their calendars are hard to get on
and i said honestly what we're going to
do is we're going to get on these buses
we're going to downtown boston
and we're going to we're going to go in
the streets and we're going to talk to
customers
and he kind of laughed he said oh i okay
just to be clear
these guys don't talk to customers
that's what i said
so so now that we know we don't have to
do that like what's the next thing we're
gonna do right
but there's this sense in organizations
that leaders don't need to take risks
that's what other people do
can you talk about your attitude
yourself as a leader because one of the
other comments you made in the blog
which i thought was spectacular was
leadership is about continuously
challenging yourself
and i don't know that i think maybe
that's a that's a really great
poster that people might put on the wall
but it's something you've embodied
and i wonder what inspired that attitude
for you
and and how do you continue to stoke it
because the tendency is to be
comfortable
and get insulated how do you keep
provoking yourself and keep challenging
yourself
yeah i think it's kind of you you can
easily get comfortable and i could tell
you there's been parts in my career that
i've gotten comfortable but
you know when you're uneasy you're not
happy where things are
you can either continue to complain or
you can do something about it and and
what i wanted to do is
i wanted to do something about it so i
knew i needed to force something i
didn't know
where i wanted to go i didn't know where
it was but you're gonna
have a bit of leap of faith to say you
know what i want to go in this general
direction i want to keep learning um and
i could say that appetite for learning
curiosity keeping an open mind
has been key because i've learned a lot
from yourself from
from justin and others and funny enough
i don't have to create all this stuff
i actually learn from people who have
done it elsewhere
and i can bring it back and have a great
impact and never they'll say hey that's
great that worked out well
but it's not something like i have to
develop it all myself and it all has to
come out of me
i i really learned from the masters and
figured out
hey these are proven techniques that
work really well
and i can bring them back and so what i
wanted to do
is create something of value that would
have an impact
and so i think that was the intent once
i realized the power
of what design thinking could do i
wanted to say
how do i create that awareness uh and
more general right so i didn't want to
just say all right i want
everybody to turn into a designer it was
how do i
create that appetite in that awareness
for enough people that they may want to
go
up that scale so you know give them a
curated content
on awareness you can get certified or
you can be a master designer
and and give them that ability and i
think the
the what we've seen and i don't know if
any of you guys follow on linkedin but
if you just go to
the hsbc underscore dt
you could see people and this is not
scripted this is their
own feelings on the course and the
impact it's had on their lives
and in their jobs and to me that's what
brings me satisfaction
is the ability that i can have an impact
to others and make their
work and personal lives better
i wonder if you wouldn't mind steve to
give us a concrete example because one
of the things you say you kind of you
gave a little teaser in your
second blog post but you mentioned it
was your responsibility to lead
idea management and experimentation and
drive proofs of concept like chat bots
things like that and you said
it genuinely helped us avoid pitfalls in
the early days of the program
and i wonder for folks who are thinking
about undertaking a design driven
approach
when you say it helped us avoid pitfalls
what specifically
did design thinking illuminate that
you know what what did it help you avoid
that you would have maybe stumbled over
had you not used this approach
well i i think people are a lot more
open in there they allow
time for design today where in the past
like you said it's kind of it feels like
a fluffy thing right
so when i took your course one of the
first steps
of your course in empathize was to
empathize
and can you imagine me working in risk
going to the senior management of risk
saying oh guys i found the solution
it's called empathy and then they kind
of look at me cross-eyed say what
you know get back to work and and so
really
understanding how do i translate that so
that people can see the value of what
comes out
the the other side you know i i've heard
feedback on people that have taken the
101 course in the awareness course
that they took the course it really
opened their eyes and they took
that and applied it to different
programs in the bank
and um you know because we're in early
days we're actually going to document
all those programs
and put testimonials um on
what and the impacts it's had but people
from developing new products
uh new p pocs approval concepts
um it's helped them make sure that
they're working on the right
what um and that's what's important
because
we all have limited time we have limited
resources and we want to make sure we're
using our time
uh in the best impactful way if that
makes sense
yeah absolutely absolutely yeah one of
my favorite quotes is a problem well put
is half solved
and having that that uh that sense of
the biggest thing we can do
is identify the right for the problem
we're solving we can solve almost
anything most
most failures aren't values of execution
they're they're solving against the
wrong
problem itself so that's great what are
what are some of these
if i could add on the quote because i
you've given me a quote i want to give
you a quote back
so i really like einstein's quote i
don't know if you know einstein's quote
it says and i've i've put it here so i'd
make sure i've got it if i had an
hour to solve a problem i would spend
55 minutes thinking about the problem
and
five minutes solving that problem and
it's funny you've got
one of the people that are considered
the most smartest people in the
person in the world and his approach
what he just said
is a design thinking approach right
and focus on the what not the solutions
focus on the problem and make sure you
understand that problem
and even back then i don't know when
design thinking was first
first came up maybe you can give us the
history on that but
you know you've got einstein they're
talking about how he approaches problems
in a design thinking way
yeah it's beautiful yeah i love that too
it's it's uh it's so
counter to you know the the conventional
mindset i think we talk about this in
the dt101 course
um which we've rolled out in your
organization is
is implement this solution that's
problem solving implement this solution
and what we say is okay let's do a
couple of things one let's say
is that the right solution and let's
generate lots of options before we
decide on what to implement but two
and maybe as you're saying even more
importantly let's make sure that's the
right problem
to be solved and let's generate all the
problems that could be solved and then
pick the one that's most important to
solve
and it's those two kind of outputs of
not only
what's the solution but also what's the
problem to be solved
it's a radical paradigm shift for a lot
of people and a lot of people
really it's liberating too to realize oh
i can
question the problem you know the the
old
joke how many designers does it take to
change a light bulb
do you know no i don't know that one
doesn't have to be a light bulb yeah
exactly thank you yeah but the but it's
there's really a sense of
uh of liberty that comes when you say
let's actually see if this is the right
problem to be solved and a lot of times
the answer is no the answer is no
hi jeremy just to finish off on on the
history i wanted to kind of show two
pictures
and um and you you haven't seen one of
these pictures before so i thought i'd
kind of surprise you so robin if you
don't mind putting the pictures of the
videos
i i guess jeremy back in 2018 was when i
captured this moment for you and perry
um i was going there for the graduation
ceremonies when i did
my innovation entrepreneurship program
and i remember
you had hundreds of people around you
talking about oh i loved it and whatever
and i and and i was talking to my wife
at the time and she's like well why
don't you pull these guys aside and see
if
you know they'll record a video and you
guys can talk about how do you develop a
program you can bring
back to the bank and you and i i
mentioned it to you like oh that's a
fantastic idea
and then we walked away from the crowd
and we just started we recorded a two
minute video
right then and there at the ceremony
both you and perry were nice enough to
do it
but i wanted to show you another picture
uh because i was really excited to come
to the school and i was hoping that i
got to meet you guys
and a lot of the different professors
well this is the picture
the lady sitting behind you was my wife
or is my wife
and she was sitting there to make sure
she got good pictures and then these two
rock stars come in
jeremy and perry and i'm like oh my god
there they are and i'm sitting there
saying
uh taking a picture and i'm messaging my
wife i'm like those those are the guys i
was telling you about
and funny nothing guys you guys sat
right in front of her so i thought
i thought i'd share that moment with you
it was a special moment for me anyway
that's awesome
that's amazing that's amazing steve it's
humbling we
we uh we're fortunate to get to have you
in our life so it's pretty cool that
there's a there's a reciprocal
appreciation that's awesome
gentlemen one of the questions that that
is coming up is one that we get
frequently
which is um essentially you know we love
the design thinking 101 course
but then what do we do next how do we
start to implement it
what are the best practices for rolling
that out and what kind of guard rails
you know did you learn steve and and how
you started to spread it
um yeah so for us in the bank um we have
the 101 the 101 is the awareness so
it like i said in in the past we're not
looking to create designers
of all of our 200 000 plus employees
but the people who do do want to take it
further
we're giving them 102 a 103
and we've got a learning path to kind of
get to that
that certified the other people i wanted
to have that awareness is when you see
it let's make sure we're applying it
use the questions use the challenging um
that
design thinking teaches you and when
you're seeing being applied be part of
the solution right
so be open to suggestions a lot of times
people throw an idea out there that you
you don't like or you don't think it'll
work
your first reaction is to shut it down
maybe take the different approach to say
well how could i make this work does it
really make sense
and think about um instead of saying but
say well what if uh or better yet
i think you guys have that better yet uh
comment and
having that open mind to say well
you know maybe there's something here to
drive that out
and i think that kind of opens up to
newer opportunities
yeah i would say one thing that and i i
just dropped it in the chat and maybe
the team can share it in the chat as
well the uh
one of the big things i'd say is
creating
space it's uh in your in your actual
calendar
i i cannot emphasize enough that in the
in this era the zoom era and the modern
work
space it's truly
in like uh just incredible how people's
calendars drive their time
and there's a sense like a lot of times
what i what i hear folks say is
i don't have time to experiment i don't
have time to
interview somebody and what i found is a
very simple reframe is
whenever you find yourself saying i
don't have time to blank
instead say i haven't made time to blank
right so if you feel you don't have time
to experiment say i haven't
made time to experiment and you know i
was in a meeting the other day with a
with an irish executive who she's
working to bring experimentation into
her
team she's she's the head of a major
department a major tech company
and she said jeremy this is wednesday
morning
this is my 29th meeting of the week you
know when do you expect me to do this
and i just said and i i
get it but but i pushed back and i said
here's what you should do and this is
the
the article that i just linked to i said
pull up a granted this week's crazy pull
up your calendar for next week
create a calendar event for an hour and
once and we talked about the experiment
she needed to run
the the subject line of your calendar
event is run
the blank experiment which involves
sending an a b test kind of email kind
of a thing
i said okay i did it and i said now five
three days later
at another calendar event and the
subject line is
review the data from ap experiment that
i launched on monday right
and and what i call this is writing a
love note to yourself the
basic idea is present me often hates
past me
because past me has booked a bunch of
meetings that keeps me from doing the
stuff i really want to do right
so if i want to in a sense a way to do
myself a favor in the future is to block
time to do the thing that i wish i could
do right now right
and so it's finding a way instead of say
you know
holding up your calendar as an excuse
for why you can't work differently
use judo so to speak to wield your
calendar and to create space
to do the kinds of things that you want
to do like experiment
like ideation like engaging with
customers
and a lot of times if if you don't feel
like you're the owner of your calendar
you then
you need to take a little bit more
ownership and sometimes it means you
know when i realized this by the way a
few months ago wow
especially in this you know uh covid era
there's this meeting after meeting after
meeting well
i only accept meetings if i have free
time
so you know what i do i started blocking
time pro
preemptively proactively for the stuff
that i care about right
it's a really simple tactic but i find
that that you know
danny kahneman the behavioral
psychologist um
he talks about this this is something
that's been very helpful for me to
realize too
when you're seeking to create behavior
change there's basically two forces that
play with behavior change there's
what are called driving forces meaning
things that motivate the behavior change
and then there's restraining forces
which are things that prevent the
behavior change
and a lot of times when we're trying to
advocate for behavior change we
our tactics are around driving forces
encouraging
incentivizing motivating reminding etc
and what kahneman says is actually a
much more elegant solution
is instead to remove a restraining force
and instead of saying how do i get
somebody to do blank
say why aren't they already doing it now
and if i can remove that restraining
force and for me
all that say the calendar isn't it is a
and the meeting-centric culture
is a restraining force to many people
and if we start to
remove that restraining force it opens
up the ability
to engage some of these new tools
that's wonderful i'm yeah
sorry i'm i'm there's so there are so
many questions coming in and i am i'm
both listening
jeremy and steve to what you're saying
and i'm responding to people in the q a
i figure that's a good thing
i'm getting messages i'm getting
messages saying justin is covering all
the questions really well
i i can't do both at the same time i
gotta focus on
who's talking and i get all this stuff
coming so you're doing really well
great well there are a few thank you
there are a few things i want to elevate
so
a common theme is you know the
the the internal obstacles um
my interpretation is in an operational
culture
where there is a lot to do all of the
time
how do you make room for this new way of
working that
won't show linear outcomes right
so steven your experience maybe if you
talk about that a bit
you know first you kind of you kind of
we have to win through successes and you
have to show
the value that comes out of this right
and there's a lot of really good
examples in the market
a well-designed product or a
well-designed
process has x amount more value
and delivery and uptake than uh
something that that
that isn't and so what i'd like to kind
of put
is to show listen if we do this there's
going to be a lot more value
and you're going to get exactly what you
want and then people are like well you
know what i'm too busy i just want to
get on and get started with it
and what people don't understand is then
there's a lot more rework
you miss the point and then you may even
miss the opportunity
and so if i show by doing it this way
and having the faith that we can do it
um
that they can do it and they're starting
to see it and and now they're actually
leaving space for design and actually
asking those questions
well you know have we looked at design
what what is that customer journey
um how does this apply and you've got
you know executives
now demanding to make sure that it the
design
it's the design-led change um which is
great that's exactly what we want to do
so but you have to do it through success
you can't just assume
that hey guys i read this thing and it's
a great thing and it's design thinking
and you got to trust me and you got to
do it you got to really show
through through success how it works
and then once they start believing it
they're gonna
and i see it people are pushing it
themselves
i i really like this question steve i
see from the uh
from the chat based on your experience
what advice can you give
finance leaders to permeate design
thinking in teams with the
operational activities
yeah you know i i guess we can number
one
is take the time and do the course right
so understand design thinking i often
get times oh i already know what it is
or this is all common sense really kind
of stop
listen understand um and i think what
has made your course very successful
guys is that you guys are incredibly
engaged in
engaging so we've broken out the courses
in little 15-minute bites
and so that's enough for people to kind
of just take a couple minutes of their
day
listen to the course and and take some
of that
and really uh being able to apply it so
uh you know i thought that was that was
a great way of getting that course
instead of just sitting down
for a couple of hours that people just
can't do and do that
by doing that it helps them understand
certain processes or things that they
can look at
and so you know oftentimes i like you
know what steve i don't have time to
innovate
or i don't have time to make this
process better even if you might have a
solution for them
and i and and i say well you you
actually you do have time
you have you don't have time not to
listen to it and
um and again as you start showing uh
products and assets that they start
seeing that could be a value that makes
their
work and life better they're never going
to go back to the old ways of doing
things
steve here's a big one that i know came
up for us in our work together
how the pandemic affect this effort to
bring design thinking
to the organization it was funny because
and justin i can tell you i remember uh
when i first kicked off in calling
jeremy and i sent jeremy an email
through
his uh i think it was his gmail account
and then he was like oh yes we could do
this and you know jeremy's a ball of
energy he's like oh we could do this and
we could do this and do this
and then he brought perry in and then
something happened where perry couldn't
come and then they brought you in justin
and you know the chemistry and what you
and i were talking about worked out so
well
they were like all right let's get this
contract signed it took us a couple
months to get the contract signed
but finally we got through the contracts
we got through all the legal piece
who owns what how do we get this up and
running and
we're sitting there ready to go you
actually had bought your ticket
i i put you at the hotel where we're
gonna run the course
and the world health organization says
all right stop all travel stop falling
there's a world pandemic and we have to
stop
and literally it happened the week that
you were meant to come to london
uh to get this done and so we had to
pivot right
and i was thinking at that point i
thought it was over right i thought okay
i lost my money
with the hotel you know i we paid
stanford to kind of come over here and
do all this other stuff
uh but funny enough you guys had the
right mindset and i think everybody
wanted to see this happen
where we all pivoted say all right now
we're in this situation
what can we do now to make this
successful and i think that's where
we actually did a pilot program a couple
months later
and we did it through zoom and it was
the first time you guys had
brought this together and you're like
all right bear with us so you know we
used the design thinking
prototyping um to do it we did a
prototype
it worked really well we got a lot of
great feedback but we got a lot of
feedback so we incorporated that
feedback to the end product
that just made that end product that
much better
oh god justin i was going to say
you know some of the principles that we
learned in that
you all uh who are with us today are
struggling with you know innovation amid
the pandemic
one of the principles we learned was the
sort of inherent trust
with each other you know it's it's hard
to navigate
the uncertainty of not knowing if you
don't trust
one that together you will get to
an amazing outcome and two that everyone
individually is doing their best
right and so this relationship that we
have with steve
and you can tell just by the way he
talks there's a lot of
trust given even before it's you know
earned in
in time or however else we build trust
so
i think that's a big one in in the
pandemic is how do you extend
trust to each other and as you as you
navigate
the uncertainty of logistics and
learning
and collaboration and all those things
you know there's something too that i
think is worthwhile to mention here
which is around reflection
and it's one thing to learn but it's
another thing to actually reflect on how
things went
because we talked about beginning to
make small
applications and creating the space for
teams who are learning new tools to
actually reflect on how things went
i is that's part of trust building to be
able to give feedback to be able to
share to kind of dissect an experience
and say where did things work
and where could we improve next time
steve i wonder
as i look at these questions one of the
things that's striking me is
where do we where have you seen early
success in bridging from
learning to application because you
you cover a bunch of different teams
have you seen
any particular parts of the organization
respond more quickly to application
to practice than others and what do you
what do you draw from those observations
uh yeah and i would love to bring this
example and kind of share this example
but i don't want to steal that team
slender
but i'll give you at a high level
without giving you too much detail
there was a big program that we just
rolled out and it was a very
visual program and the team that
rolled it out said i took your design
thinking course
i loved it i want to apply it to this
program
um and we sat down we iterated with them
they rolled out the program last uh
three weeks
ago it was a huge success
and uh and they attribute a lot of that
success was because
they they learned the design thinking
methods they applied that design
thinking methods to the program steve
what do you see uh
what do you see is next for the
transformation when
now that you've got this this
this activated network of design
thinkers
what neck what's next and how do you
think about shepherding the energy
and the enthusiasm and the capability
that you've been developing inside the
organization
yeah i think we're in the start of it
and just so you know i mean there's a
whole crew of people
and a lot of people that are part of a
design community so
it's not just like uh i did it i i had a
whole team behind me and these guys were
just relentless on wanting to get this
out
so a lot of credit really goes out to
the team
and the people that are part of the
design at work
at hsbc so i don't want to give you or
anybody the impression it's a one person
thing
this is uh hard work to a bunch of
people
like minded that want to make an impact
so
we created the awareness we will really
want to take again
that upper level to say how do we use
that design and how do we push it out
there
i think we're still need to make a lot
more progress in that area
and figuring out how do we design better
systems and i can tell you it's a
never-ending process right
because the good thing about innovation
is there's always things to innovate
things to make better um and that's what
i like about my job i can't be bored at
my job
because if you don't like the way it is
today don't worry tomorrow it's going to
change
right you know
one of the one of the things a question
that just came through the chat which i
think is great is this uh someone says
i work in risk management i head the
risk function at a company overseeing
units in 10 different countries can you
give examples of how you applied design
thinking in the context of risk
management in particular
um yeah i think you know maybe we'll go
back to
the mri and you guys could probably
answer this better than i can so the mri
or um the baby blanket warmer stuff
right
and you know that that's about risk
management this is about human lives and
how that impact has
or even mris if you can't produ if you
can't get an mri to work great because
people don't know how to engage or or
the kids they didn't want to get in
there because it was too scary and noisy
um you know you have to look at that and
i think the same thing with risk
management
you have to understand what is it that
you're trying to achieve
and is there a better way to achieve it
or are you putting in
a process or a procedure for
something that's an exception that
people really don't need and it's really
kind of constantly challenging yourself
what is the objective that you're trying
to achieve and is there a better way to
achieve that objective
through a dif through a different lens i
don't know if you guys want to mention
kind of
the mri because i think the ge mri
examples fantastic or or even the the
the baby warmers out of nepal if i
if i've got that right
yeah justin you want to mention the i
think embrace is a great example
yeah i mean there's so many lessons from
from that
work that those students and and now
that company is doing
the big one for me is around problem
framing
which has also come up in the in the
chat from participants today
and you know oftentimes we frame
the problem we're trying to solve around
what we already do
right because it's where we're
comfortable and so if we frame the
problem around the noun
or around the outcome in this case they
were asked to design a lower cost
incubator for a hospital
right well we know what that outcome is
going to be it's going to be a lower
cost incubator for the hospital because
the solution's built into
how they're asking the question right
what they did instead was they went uh
to nepal
they interviewed people and in their
interviewing getting proximate with the
people they're trying to serve they
noticed there was a different problem
that wasn't being met and so they
reframed it
on the behavior right in this case how
to help a mother get her baby from the
hospital and the reframe around the
behavior opened up more possibilities
for solutions
because they were no longer trying to
redesign an outcome
they were trying to design for a
behavior and interaction
and that's what led to the innovation
that now has helped save the lives of
more than 300 000 babies around the
world so it's an amazing
case amazing example um but it's a it's
a simple lesson in problem framing
right if you're redesigning the thing
it's probably going to be incremental
innovation incremental better version of
the thing
but if you're designing for a human
behavior
then that opens so many more
possibilities and it just depends on
what is your intent
are you going for or innovation
incremental or are you going for
something entirely new and
by the way those are complementary we
need both of those things
especially in in a company we have to
get better at the things that people are
coming to us for so
and the new has much higher risk you
know
and then it's funny
sorry in that example the funny thing is
when i heard that first example
my first instinct was how do i make a
cheaper nikku how do i get cheaper
plastics how do i get a cheaper machine
you know these machines are a hundred
thousand dollars there's got to be a way
to make it twenty thousand dollars
but then and again that's kind of the
penny dropping
was i solving for the physicians or the
doctors or the hospital
or was i really solving for the baby and
to be honest with you i forgot about the
baby in that situation
and that's who you should be solving for
and i was solving for the wrong person
uh and design thinking helped me
understand that
and that's kind of when i had some of
those aha moments
i saw i'm looking at some of the
questions and i see
my brother in dallas has asked the
question how do you apply this to sales
culture
i think that's ex you answered that uh
and i'm also looking at some of these
people i got uh some people
some friends from kazakhstan on and some
people from hong kong
it's crazy that we have people from all
around the world so great
to see the participation you guys you
guys know how to draw a crowd
you know you know one thing i'll mention
here there's a couple of questions that
i'll just read
how do you make sure teams in a
corporate environment implement their
projects and prototypes after their work
sessions
and then there's another question which
is seemingly unrelated but it's actually
very related which is
how do small tech startups with limited
resources in a slightly chaotic
environment get buy-in from the ceo to
invest
and what i'd say is these the answer to
both those questions is
actually the same which is you want to
scope
down the work the next steps so small
that it's embarrassing to have not taken
it basically
you want to crack and i posted a link
hopefully the team can post a link
at stanford we teach a class called
launchpad and there's a worksheet
there's a series of simple worksheets
but the one i want to draw everyone's
attention to
is a worksheet which is we call the
innovator's hypothesis or the founder's
hypothesis
but if you can quickly establish what we
the the human pain point we're trying to
solve
how we think we can solve it who has
that pain point then you can say what's
something we could try
in two hours we advocate what we call a
two hour experiment we don't spend any
more time than two hours
structuring some kind of clever
interaction to test a hypothesis around
your idea but that's how both
teams in corporate environments
implement and how small tech startups
with limited resources
in a chaotic environment can get buy-in
it's by making
the uh by lowering the bar to take
action
so much that you go well there's no i
mean many times especially in
corporations
meetings end with what with a resolution
to have another meeting
right that's how most meetings end let's
talk about this again
but the thing is unless there's new
information there's not a new
conversation
and what experimentation does and you if
you look at that worksheet you'll see
is it just simply has a a founder or an
innovator
state what their hypothesis is and push
themselves to craft
a clever experiment to test that
hypothesis and so what i would say is in
in the in the context of a corporation
especially how do you make sure people
implement their projects
by the end of the conversation if the
meeting ends with a resolution to have
another meeting which they often do
at the very least establish ownership
who's going to commission an experiment
actually conduct the experiment what
kind of data are we hoping to see from
that experiment
could be open rate click-through rate
you know response rate whatever it is
right
and when and what is the threshold that
will help us know whether this is
something we should move forward or not
if there's
very very simple alignment around
ownership and objective the two o's you
might say
um then it's worth having another
meeting
most of the time though what happens is
it's like this vague yeah we don't
really know
and we're not really sure so let's talk
about it later as if time
is somehow going to give us more insight
it's not
action is what gives us more insight but
you've got to have a nice tight scaffold
for supporting action and that's where a
lot of folks fall down
i don't know go ahead what were you
saying
no no no i completely agree with you and
i think kind of
you're going to learn by doing and the
if you can make that process
cheap fast frictionless
and the more you do it the faster you do
it and you iterate
the faster you're doing it faster than
your competitors
and i think the pace of change is what's
going to be key
for people to keep up because if you
can't keep up with the pace of change i
think
going back to all the quotes i like i
think it was jack welsh that said
if your competitor is changing faster
than you can
or then you are then game over and so
i think that's key and i remember in
your program
you you gave an example of the guy that
developed
an aircraft out of man-made power
that went across the english channel and
how he solved that
was about making it cheap fast and easy
and that was one of those things to say
that's the secret to innovation if i can
make innovation
frictionless as cheap as possible get
people to learn quickly
then people can do this really quickly
they'll learn what doesn't work
we can share those ideas and we can
learn off of each other and we don't
have to do
duplicate duplicity work where that's
very expensive
and everybody has to learn every problem
what will work or what
would not work so yeah that's kind of
some of the really cool things that i
got out of it um i did see one of the
questions i think amanda venus talked
about
uh fear of failure and i think that
stops a lot of people
right so i'd like to kind of i don't
know justin or jeremy kind of get your
guys
is how do you overcome that fear and
um failure is part of the equation so so
what do you guys
do to kind of give people that
confidence to keep going
and understanding that to me i mean a
very simple
uh a very very simple way to think about
it
is to set the expectation of cycles
of learning so nothing has ever worked
on its first try
ever right so if if you don't fail
you'd basically be the first person in
the history of the world for a new idea
to work immediately right
so like cue the nobel prize ceremony
right
so instead say have the expectation of
learning comes in cycles you know the
the the simple example is wd-40 you know
why wd-40 is called wd-40
it's it's what happens when an engineer
gets in charge of branding it's
water displacement 40. it's the 40th
iteration of the
formula to displace water which is to
say
a well-funded team with a very clear
problem
took 40 tries to get it right right most
innovation efforts are less well-funded
and they're less clear where they're
going right
are they going to take more or less than
40 tries they're probably going to take
more than 40.
but if you have this mindset of our goal
is actually cycles
and what we're trying to do is not get
right
it's not it's not find the right answer
but it's eliminate wrong answers quickly
you know the old edison adage i
didn't fail ten thousand times i just
found ten thousand things that don't
work
an experimental mindset is is
largely indifferent to to failure
because
it's it's eliminating non-viable
pathways
and with a new idea what you want to do
is you want to recognize
we don't have it right the first time
but the only way to learn how to make it
right
is to keep trying and to keep iterating
and so paying more attention to
your learning speed you know there's a
great podcast um
mark randolph the founder co-founder of
netflix with reed hastings
he talked with tim ferriss recently and
he talked about how in the early days of
netflix
long before they knew they were netflix
right they were trying a
customized shampoo subscription and a
customized
dog treat recommendation in gen and also
dvds by mail right they were doing tons
of stuff
in the early days he talked about that
they would commission these beautiful
experiments that took
you know multiple weeks to to uh to
gather data
and then you know what they learned it
took them weeks to
realize that they didn't have the right
idea and so then they said they became
obsessed with can we make it one week
instead of two
to learn and then they said can we make
it three times a week instead of once a
week and then can we make it
once a day and then can we make it
multiple times a day but he said we
became obsessed with this idea of
developing a system to quickly test bad
ideas
and i think that is actually the core
it's not it's not how do you deal with
failure it's it's recognizing
if you're trying to do something new you
have to be in hyper learning mode
and in hyper learning mode you're you're
you're running a marathon you're running
laps i don't know how many laps around
to track a marathon is but it's not a
400 meter sprint
you're running laps and what we'd say is
and i think steve can speak to this as
well
a lap has to include the customer right
if the customer's not involved you
haven't made a lap yet right but that's
a simple way to think about it
and if you foreground the importance the
imperative of learning
then it means that failure you reframe
failure it's not failure it's just
learning and you take it in stride
you keep going and you know great one
cycle down
39 to go one cycle down 38 to go
etc etc i don't know steve or justin if
you have other thoughts there but that
that to me is a is a radical reframe and
it's a critical thing for folks who are
trying to do something new
now i think that's fantastic and it's a
great example
um justin i saw you answered a question
and bonnie bonnie chung actually one of
the people calling from hong kong
and so and i saw her 55-5 rule
i i haven't heard that so would you mind
just elaborating for the people on the
call
what is that fifty five five rule
well i think she three to the fifteen
five when you were talking about
einstein's quote
i thought that's what i thought that's
what she meant was the spend
you know thinking about it before you
jump in
yeah yeah and and what i was trying to
convey in that answer
is that to me
part of the beauty is design pedagogy is
that
within it there are a series of tasks to
achieve
but none of the tasks to achieve are
necessarily the final outcome you're
trying to get to
right and but because there are tasks to
achieve
it helps achievement-oriented people
like myself
people who are type a you know who have
a lot of tasks in their normal work
it helps them engage in something
that actually pushes them to behave
differently
right and so what i was suggesting to
to to her was
you know give people a task that
actually
has them think more than they have to do
so rather than just convincing them to
do it
you give them a worksheet or you give
them a framework or you say hey this
came from stanford or this came from
some other
you know uh brand that they uh that that
they respect or have heard of right
you're creating wedges you're creating
room for people to work differently
and then as they start to do that that
can come from start to come from them
right and then it'll cascade without
your prompts
i don't know if that makes sense but
that's that's part of what i like about
it
no absolutely
sorry i'm going to mute because i've got
jeremy to wait
what what you were saying jeremy is
failure is
is not failure it's learning right and
and to me
i i use i was responding to one of the
questions
you know i was a journalist before and i
i really like language and i use
rational language a lot right people are
not resistant to the change you want to
bring to your organization
because they are mean or because they
are not smart
or because they um are trying to hold on
to power
maybe that's true sometimes but i prefer
not to think that i prefer to think that
people are resistant to change
because we all are resistant to change
it's the power of inertia
we are comfortable doing what we've
learned
how to do and in many cases we've
created something around what we're good
at
and so it's hard to say i'm gonna try
something that i've never done
and because i've never done it i'm not
gonna be good at it who
am i if i'm making mistakes all the time
right and that's a difficult thing
and then in an organization we often
don't incentivize that behavior
so but if you want to create something
that's never been done then you have to
do something different
you can't do the same thing you've
always done and expect a different
outcome
that's the definition of insanity right
so
if we're going to do something different
we're inevitably going to make mistakes
we're going to learn from those mistakes
in order to determine what we're going
to do next
okay so that's my narrative that's the
way i describe it all the time and i
think the language of it
i so that's what i call rational
language doesn't that make sense
we can agree to that i can see you're
nodding steve and and jeremy right
now now we got to do it right that's
where it gets hard if we can all agree
we have to do something different to
begin the journey to creating something
that's never been done
that's that's a good place to start once
we agree now we can start doing it and
that's where
you know you encounter other obstacles
so anyway
try rational language with people people
one very simple
yeah i just add to that justin i love
that i would add if you're if you're a
manager and you're trying to build this
sense of resilience on your team a very
very simple
tactic to create permission and also
create a pull for this kind of behavior
is
just to say what else are we trying what
else are we trying
yeah not in a not in a demanding way but
in a really we only have one answer here
like what else are we trying you know
and you know instead of bringing me one
option
bring me five options let's let's try
that instead of telling me how one thing
went
tell me how five things went you know in
the early days of amazon i was just
reading a
biography of bezos and he has the just
do it award where every year they would
reward someone for taking a bold action
that didn't pan out very well right and
so it's
how do you think about rewarding a
different kind of action how do you
think about
eliciting a different kind of action i
work with another executive team where
they ask everybody to come in with a
piece of inspiration from
the weekend right so there are different
ways where you can
trigger and and create space for new
kinds of behaviors
but i love that that simple rational
kind of explanation
if you want something different you have
to do something different
and for the big challenge is
how do you create the permission to do
something different recognizing that
you want something different on the
other side and that's really what i
think steve has done a great job
of doing in his organization and i would
say just as a teaser to the next one
we're very excited to hear from some of
the people for whom he's created that
space
so thank you steve for allowing us to
have a little bit of window of insight
and we're excited to learn from the
folks who you want to brag on and whose
stories you didn't want to tell
we're excited to hear from them come
september
guys guys i'm very honored that you guys
allowed me to kind of share my story
with you guys
and i really appreciate it and i love uh
the the
the friendship and the work that we've
done together so
really proud of it robin i guess you're
already ready to
passing it back to yourself so oh jordy
the conversation thank you so much
all of you for the very interesting and
insightful
hour that we spent i feel like we
answered a lot of questions and had some
really great conversation
thank you thanks steve for joining us to
everyone in the audience with us live
today thank you for your questions and
participation
it really makes the whole experience
just that much more
interesting and joyful if you enjoyed
the conversation
and are interested in learning more it
would be a great idea if you check out
the creativity and design thinking
program which is linked in your
dashboard with that really fun and
colorful
image and that's it we're signing off
from stanford
and justin you're signing off from
hawaii and c from london and jeremy i
think you're about 10 minutes away
from me so everyone thank you so much
for the great conversation we appreciate
it bye everyone
you